it's four years since British forces
ended their combat mission in
Afghanistan but flying into Kabul is
still done in pitch darkness and in the
dead of night at the request of
Washington the British government has
sent 400 more troops to the country and
we flew in with some of them
blocking left turning left Kabul is
still a fortress coalition forces patrol
and escort officials in heavily armored
vehicles
US and British helicopters buzz over the
city in pairs
but notably on the ground it is the
Afghan security forces who are now
responsible for securing the city the
Afghan government strategy has been to
concentrate on the security of the major
cities like Kabul but that has left a
lot of the rural areas open and that has
been exploited by the Taliban they've
taken a lot of that ground and they use
them as springboards in order to launch
attacks in major urban areas and often
to deadly Authority last month a suicide
bomber blew himself up and killed 48
students at an Education Center in Kabul
is la McStay t' claimed responsibility
for that one it's estimated that there
are now thousands of foreign Islamic
state fighters in Afghanistan they have
moved from Iraq and Syria they've
established a network here and they are
growing stronger visiting British troops
in Afghanistan the defense secretary
told us that for the first time
intelligence has been found establishing
a direct link back to terror cells in
the UK we consistently see we're seeing
the terrorist groups operating here in
Afghanistan evidence of their links back
not just of a United Kingdom but a whole
of continental Europe what we see is a
real threat posed by posed by these
groups to the United Kingdom
that growing threat is why the British
government agreed to send more troops to
Afghanistan one of their jobs will be
training new recruits at this officer
training academy in the hills outside
Kabul there is no shortage of volunteers
and this is the latest in take place you
want to be free it is still hard to see
a time when coalition forces could leave
Afghanistan this is a long-term
commitment with a long time left to run
peace talks have been proposed and might
well happen that in mind though every
side is now trying to strengthen their
hand and that will almost certainly mean
more violence
Alistair bungle Sky News Kabul in
Afghanistan